keep going I can't give you any more
instruction I've been more than clear
one two three four who 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 1
14 all right I'm y go ahead now go nine
back right one 2 3 4 4 5 6 7 8 9 keep
going hello afternoon hi offic good
afternoon how are you good officer and
reg pleas thank you officer Anderson
Police Department good just wearing a
bodying camera it's recording okay I I
you live here correct yes sir okay so
while just while we're doing this I'm
just going to ask you to stay in the car
please don't get out um until we uh can
kind of get through this okay absolutely
so yes sir EXC I got to go to work okay
I'll have this officer move that in just
a second okay he pulled me over for I
was stopped at the stop sign I don't
know he was coming from the left side I
don't know yeah so I was just going to
explain so the reason why I stopped you
is we got a call Medford actually
specifically got a call Kyle he's got to
back out do you mind just moving my car
over so he can back this is your car
right here so I apologize sir
yeah can you not leave and make sure all
right thank you okay um so anyway so we
got an eratic driver call Medford guy
call over to us I'm just I have no idea
what we even I came from the nail salon
I went from Burger King to from the nail
okay I wasn't even driving at all okay
yeah
so yeah so all I know is that Medford
got a call I guess in the area of the
Acme uh for ertic driver somebody oh I'm
just I'm just let let me let me relay
what I was told yeah cuz like I said I I
know when too many hands get caught in
the pot sometimes it can be a little
confusing so um Medford received Med
Medford Township Police received a call
from an erratic driver in the area of
the Acme okay and whoever called that in
who I have not spoken with they specify
they they describe the vehicle they
match it with your registration okay
that's fine all right so that's that's
all that's all I'm doing is to come out
and follow up and kind of see what's
going on I just came from getting my
nails done okay where did you get your
nails done Orchard Nails where I no idea
what it is I could pull it it's that no
no I can pull it up on my GPS hold on
one second I don't know exactly cuz I
used to go to Hollywood in uh Westfield
Avenue okay so I could tell you exactly
where it is or hold on on my
GPS I just came from
there Orchard Nails it is
on it is the exact spot the directions
are 175 North Route 70 number
23 70 okay is is there a talent for that
it's just it's Medford I would believe
it's Medford New Jersey that's fine okay
so you went from the nails and then and
I went for my nails there's a Burger
King right in the spot I got Burger King
for the kids and I came back cuz my
husband has to go to work gotcha okay so
Orchard Nails you want me to give you
the exact like location no no no I
believe you if you saying it's right
there that was just more curiosity I've
never never heard of that so um okay
so okay I can do whatever you guys need
me to do okay all right we're going to
get to that honestly I want to kind of
get a little bit more detail on what the
caller had observed I don't regarding
your operation of the I came from the
Burger King and then I came down like
maybe Hartford Road I'm not 100% I don't
I'm not good with I'm not good with get
my nails done I used to get my nails on
Hollywood Nails in West Avenue and
because it's so far away I found a new
place and this is like the second or
third time I've gone to that okay all
right yeah okay because like even the
place there they were like here they
ruined your nails so bad that like they
did treatment on my I know they did
treatment on my nails like whatever all
right but from so from your perspective
in your opinion you didn't operate the
vehicle erratically you didn't there's
nothing that you can think of that you
can think like like you didn't like
swear off the road into the shoulder
onto the grass anything like that okay
um okay all right give me give me one
minute so it's in Medford the nail salon
is mar I believe you you don't have to
you're
good North New Jersey 70 okay I'll be
right back with you all right just just
just stay in the car for me all
right oh you don't have I mean obvious
she livs here I told her not to go
inside but um I got to I got to call the
call her go from there
[Applause]
okay
um
every all right Mary I'm the only Honda
on the road listen we're going to try to
get this through this quickly we're
going to do fter bodyy okay yes sir
please thank you absolutely we're just
going to step over here absolutely I
flip flops on you want your husband to
boyfriend right husband husband to grab
you um Keepers sure that's fine either
the way I'm fine are oh my God I know
these are balance test it is it is a
little here so if you want I would like
sneakers only because it's
free get your sers ready your test um
can you get my
nug no my
my they're in the Box on the top shelf
to the left of course I close the driver
side door I
want sorry guys like I said I don't know
if
she like I said we just want to make you
comfortable to go through these test no
no no I'm fine guys
I we're just going to step over here in
front of my car
okay I know it's very cold just do me a
favor just stand right here just stand
right here for me right here yep yep all
right and and then you can face me okay
face you you can face me you want me to
turn around and face you I want to do
what you're telling me to do so just
turn around and yes please okay all
right so we're going to do three tests
okay I'm going to do the first two tests
okay the first test is the walkin turn
test y right so first I'm going to
explain the test then I'm going to
demonstrate the test and then I'm going
to ask you to demonstrate the test okay
so there's a starting position for this
test all right I'm going to ask you to
get into this position now before we
start okay your right foot back left
foot in front with your heel to toes
touching so straighten your straighten
your feet out so they're in a straight
line okay like this just move yeah just
put put them in a straight line there
you go a little bit more if you
can so that makes sense like you see how
minor crooked you were crooked I'm
trying to do exactly what you say okay
that's fine left front and then just put
your hands at your siid okay so just
stay in this position while I explain
and demonstrate the test this way when
I'm done you can just begin the test
okay so what you're going to do is
you're going to take nine Heel To Toe
steps forward in a straight line so nine
heel toe so move the right to the front
first let me explain the entirety of the
test and then I'm going to demonstrate
it for you okay if you have any hold on
I'm trying okay if you have any
questions after that I'm happy to answer
them okay so try to keep can I just
stand straight for a second sure you can
take a second that's fine okay cuz I
have like when you're ready just get
back in the story you're going to take
nine Heel To Toe steps forward in a
straight line with your hands at your
sides okay got you Heel To Toe steps
okay go forth I'm freezing on your ninth
step You Can Count out loud on your
ninth step you're going to leave one
foot planted take a series of small
steps to turn around you're going to
take nine Heel To Toe steps forward
again in a straight line my nine steps n
my ninth step forward take how many
steps forward nine nine forward turn
around nine back okay all right I'm
going to demonstrate okay hands h your
sides I'm sorry I'm like really cold
you're fine so I'm in the starting
position right now one two 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
right heel to toe touching on every step
turn turn around one two three if you
step off the line if you lose your
balance anything like that correct
yourself and pick back up from where you
left off okay do you have any questions
about the test okay do you have any
injuries anything that would affect your
area to conduct this test okay so do you
have any questions about the T all right
you can begin the test when you're ready
while you do the test hands out okay
thank you how many steps nine Heel To
Toe steps forward in a straight line one
two
three four whoa five 6
7 hold on eight nine keep going whoa
keep going I can't give you any more
instruction I've been more than clear
one two three four whoa 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14
I'm go now go nine back right one 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 keep
going all right here we're going to do
the second test okay just come back over
here for me you can stand there and then
you can face me over here second test
one leg a stand okay good stand yep so
we're going to do a starting position
can you just show me what you want me to
do I'm going to I'm going to ask you to
get in the starting position which is
your feet together hands at your sides
okay I'm going to explain the test I'll
demonstrate it and I'm going to ask you
to do it okay so what you're going to do
is you're going to choose one leg
whichever one you're more comfortable
with and you're going to lift it
approximately 6 in off the ground like
that I'm going to show it to you so tell
you just stay in a starting position all
right waa can we wait till the wind
doesn't so you just I'm
going I got you got you're going to
count out loud one 1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000
you're going to keep counting until I
tell you to stop okay if you drop your
foot lose your balance anything like
that just pick back up and continue
counting from where you left off okay
while you're at 3 1,000 go to 4 1,000
don't so I I'll I'll show you right
while you're doing this test leave the
bottom of your foot parallel even with
the uh Road surface okay you're going to
look at your toes okay like this so here
here's what it's going to look like okay
I'm going to choose my right leg you can
choose whichever leg you're more
comfortable with okay 1 1,000 2 1000 3
1000 4 1000 5 1000 6 1000 until I tell
you to stop right if you drop your leg
anything like that pick back up seven
went down wherever you wherever you
stopped counting so I count that 41,000
pick up at 5 1,000 that's correct okay
do you have any questions about this
test absolutely not right hold on one
second please I got
you can I put my hood on I'm so sure
it's fine
hold I'm just like freezing
cold all right tell me when you're ready
you you can begin when you're
ready I just before you start I need you
to take your hands out of your Pock just
while you do the test that's fine
Goode 1 1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 4 1,000 5
1,000 6 1,000 7 1,000 8 1,000 9 1,000 10
1,000 11 1,000 12 1,000 13 1,000 14
1,000 15 1,000 16 1,000 17 1,000 181,000
191,000 21,000 21 1,000 22 1,000 23
1,000 24 1,000 you can stop than 25
1,000 you can stop thank
you keep my hands out of my pocket you
can put in your pocket okay cool this is
just for your eyes so it's not really a
balance all right so what I want you to
do is I want you to follow the tip of my
pen with your eyes only so what I want
try not to move your head just move your
eyes okay yes
sir
six
all right man you are underr okay oh my
God are you kidding me all right d okay
for suspected
[Music]
youi I didn't do
anything I'm
not how did i s
this so I'm going to double lock you so
they don't tighten up anymore on you
okay yes sir
um back here yeah
Mary okay um so when someone's arrested
for 450 we typically have to tell their
vehicle your husband's here so as a
sergeant I'm willing to allow him to
take custody of the vehicle as long as
you're in agreeing with it yes okay so
you're okay that your husband takes the
keys to cures your vehicle and you have
her license registra insurance yes yeah
I have that before we do that
um
Sure hold on a second so before you
before you sit down my start just going
to search you okay sure just hold on one
[Applause]
second I don't understand how I failed
the
test you can search me you want to go in
the house no I'm going to search you
right here all right Mary sure nothing
in your jacket right yeah man is there
anything legal in the vehicle no would
you do okay off Anderson uh search the
vehicle sure okay okay are you you're
okay to sign a waiver regarding that
yeah my yeah so I'm going to explain the
whole process on the waiver and I'm
going to have you sign off
on can I use theath pleas with me please
I can't help you i' had seven kids so
I'm going have to release I'm have to
say no in the waver I I cannot
I
[Applause]
hey yeah Tom
no I wanted my C bag my my hold on so so
yeah not they're not going through my
car and SE do so my Cooper my Cooper bag
where is
my no I don't have to let them search
shit I not I telling you I'm not under
the influence of anything can you tell
me where the bag is my bag never mind
I'll find it myself I'm asking her not
to go in there okay she doesn't want to
provide consent to sear that's fine she
doesn't have to okay well that's her
property so I can get whatever's in
there out of there right
necessarily once we figure out whether
she's going to give consent to search
the car or not then so initially she
said she wanted to and then now she's
saying she doesn't want to we're going
to honor her request regardless but we
still have other options like if we
wanted to get a can9 out here a track of
the car a sniff around the car we still
have that option but for now we're just
going to
[Applause]
ask I don't know if
he I don't know if she's going to sign
this fill it out in case she
does
[Applause]
ah
for
wonder if they had an MBA too this one
she initially I literally I came here I
checked I went back I went across to the
higher numbers to turn around I fig wait
as soon as I literally stopped she
pulled in she stopped at this I don't
know if I'm assuming it's right when she
saw me because that's when I changed she
stopped there making a right left and
just like was like fumbling in her lap
and all that for like 30 seconds and she
came down that's why I'm curious if you
stuck something now she's saying no get
my bag get my bag now she's conert and
then um but when I saw that too right
under like here you were take like it's
just like hanging this damage I'm
wondering if she like clip something
over in medf or or
whatever I don't know there none of the
caller was never following her while she
was driving I don't think she right yeah
I think he was just call her came from
originally from the nail
salon I don't know if it was
like she said the nail was in the same
right
there went the
bird
and then of course the fucking asshole
fucking neighbors nosy fucking pussy ass
neighbors have to come back they fucking
talk shit when you guys aren fucking
here God I
fucking Ming yeah I'm
moving
you guys fucking rather fucking K than
fucking phly than these fucking bastard
ass fucking Lon fucking
motherfuckers so what do I do I'm coming
here to do what going to be processed
for she just said I'm going to take a
breath lizer test I said I'll do
anything y'all want me to do breath
lizer whatever I didn't fucking fail
that test tell me how many fucking fat
motherfuckers take aat y'all do it don't
fucking pass this shit going try to get
through this as quick as we can so what
am I doing I'm coming here why the fuck
God like I said we're I want to call my
fucking lawyer when I get there okay we
can do that all right yep Anthony Mark
all right um so I'm going to take that
as a no on the conern yes search yeah um
how about we're turning it over to